que peut faire le maire que doit faire
le maire dans ces circonstances face à
une direction étrangères on le rappelle
mais d'une industrie avec un nombre
d'emplois très conséquents pour votre
ville allez-y marie josé fleury et puis
la parole tournera alors c'est vrai
qu'on n'a pas entendu beaucoup monsieur
meslot sur sur general electric ces
derniers temps et c'est déplorable
vous pouvez sourire effectivement ça
vous fait rire moi je trouve ça plutôt
aberrant parce que vous avez beaucoup
plus vrai quand un moment donné il
fallait devant les caméras de télévision
pour dénoncer ce qui se passait là en
tout cas je pense que ça aurait dû
pourtant alerté je veux dire on connaît
de general electric
on sait qu effectivement d'autres
entreprises et c'est là où je vous
disais tout à l'heure
qu'en fait je pense que cette crise du
coc vide non seulement s'arrête ça aura
été pour certaines entreprises un effet
d'aubaine
mais ça va permettre à d'autres de
saisir cette opportunité pour vraiment
faire des licenciements massifs moi
c'est ce qui est réellement m'inquiète
le plus
et c'est là où si vraiment vous vous
êtes un acteur et un élu de terrain un
liant entre les différents partenaires
partenaires sociaux économiques
associatifs
vous devez avoir un tissu je dirais très
étoffé pour prévoir justement ces
difficultés économiques
on est dans à belfort dans une dans une
région de mono industrie dans une région
où l'industrie de l'énergie prime
il est donc primordial de saclay à avoir
des entreprises innovantes parce qu'on a
un savoir-faire ce savoir faire c'est
alstom
on a la possibilité de développer
l'hydrogène je parle de l'hydrogène
verts bien bien évidemment pendant le
décarbonés et là je pense que en allant
chercher en ayant les bons outils
les bons relais sur le terrain on peut
s'atteler à faire venir de vrais
investisseurs et de vraies entreprises
innovantes sur notre territoire ce qui
n'est pas fait depuis six ans samia
jaber a montré que notre
désindustrialisation poser problème
alors sur le dossier general electric le
problème problème à nous c'est que le
maire a réagi et n'a pas agi parce qu'il
a été prévenu évidemment des risques qui
pesait depuis 2010 est il a fait le
choix de ne pas l'entendre sur
l'économie globalement on peut discuter
du bilan de monsieur muscle parce qu'on
n'en parle pas beaucoup de son bilan
alors il a été en effet beaucoup devant
les caméras lors de la crise mais ça
cache tout le reste parce que son bilan
économique est bien maigre
je pense par exemple
le dossier de l'injonction le centre
d'affaires de la jonction aujourd'hui
c'est combien monsieur meslot de
déficits cumulés ces 6 millions d'euros
sur la jonction l'ensemble des sociétés
qui gère ce parc d'activités on n'entend
jamais parler sur la question de l'airé
urbaine
monsieur messieurs a fait le choix de
tourner le dos à l'airé urbaine alors
que nous nous pensons que c'est à cette
échelle là que peut se construire le
développement industriel la recherche
universités du nord franche comté
il est urgent évidemment de redonner une
identité industrielle à notre nord
franche comté qui s'appuie sur nos deux
atouts l'énergie le transport à la fois
sur le ferroviaire et l'automobile et
l'énergie
celle d'aujourd'hui mais celle que nous
pourrons aussi de développer demain avec
le développement renouvelables
mathilde nassar quelle marge de
manoeuvre pour un ou une mère à l'avenir
par rapport à ces questions
industrielles alors vous faites bien de
le souligner parce que la court terme
sur j clairement c'est l'état qui a les
clés en main pour faire respecter ses
engagements hadji mais effectivement les
élus le maire ne fait que subir non pas
du tout je sais ce que je vais expliquer
les élus locaux ils peuvent créer on va
dire les conditions favorables pour
l'industrie
je partage l'idée qu'à voir un tissu
industriel comme celui qu'on a dans le
nord franche comté
c'est une chance mais ce tissu
industriel il est face à des mutations
extrêmement importante qu'il doit
réussir à faire dans le cadre notamment
de la transition écologique et il faut
l'accompagner pour cela en créant un
terrain extrêmement favorable en
articulant très étroitement les
questions d'industrie avec celle de la
recherche de l'enseignement et de
l'université et puisque le nord franche
comté est une terre de compétence on l'a
dit en matière d'automobile et puis
d'énergie nous on plaidera pour faire
installer comme a été installée il ya un
certain nombre d'années le crt à belfort
un centre national de la recherche
technologique un commissariat national à
l'hydrogène
justement et puis je rappelle qu'en plus
la ville de belfort peut aller dans ce
sens en par exemple utilisant une partie
de la flotte des véhicules en libre
service un optimaux pour les passer à
l'hydrogène et permettre ainsi des tests
et puis un développement de cette
technologie
damien meslot je vous laisse répondre
sur le maire aux abonnés absents
face à la crise à general electric et
aussi sur le centre la sphère de la
jonction sur le centre d'affaires de la
jonction nous avons lancé le centre
jonction 2 qui va créer de l'emploi
tout est vendu déjà et les gens qui
passent réalise les gens qui meurent
mais madame madame en somme indéterminée
la commerciale madame h mais lancer la
deuxième et vous nous expliquer
notamment jaber est ce que vous pouvez
avoir la correction vous ne connaissez
pas les interpelle le problème vous
m'avez déjà posé une question
laissez-moi répondre sur le loup blanc
sont la jonction de ces 450 emplois qui
vont assister regarder ce qui se passe à
besançon et qui ne semble d'avoir mis ce
niveau c'est qu'ils ne sont pas remises
en cause par la crise sanitaire a parce
que liam ou pas je vous rappelle qu'en
matière d'industrialisation nous avons
réussi à obtenir le centre mondial
estime en matière d'hydrogène qui va
être un centre mondial de qualification
et de test pour les réservoirs
automobiles qui va être installé sur les
remarques de fontaine il y en a cinq
dans le monde
nous avons installé magnetto automotive
sur le thé clown c'est 120 emplois d'un
grand sous traitants industriels de
l'automobile qui vient italien il ya
1500 emplois sur deux plateformes
logistiques
les permis de construire déposés sont
imposés sans les payer à paimpont madame
chabert est ce que vous pouvez être un
peu moins agressive le cinéma gens
s'exprimer mais s'est dit aux
belfortains que c'est bien amazon mais
madame madame chabert vailog qui a
déposé son permis de on a eu la tournée
aujourd'hui mais vous avez toujours des
as forme ces libérations ccls que vdoc
travaillera pour amazon motion en ciel
pour le moment nous ne savons pas encore
ce qui sait ce qu'ils ne savaient rien
il ya 1500 emplois qui vont être créés
moisson je trouve comme l ami geoffrey
damien meslot la drogue nous allons
c'est par centaines et par milliers
depuis quelques mois
est ce que ne sont ils pas remise en
cause c'est une vraie question de fond
ne sont ils pas remise en cause et
menacés par la crise sanitaire
puisqu'on fait qu'il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises ce qui me laissait filer
ces dernières semaines mais opposants
quand une bonne nouvelle pour bel fra
sépare nos opposants qui vous pose la
question sans nasri blessé un journal il
est chez risque
réunissant il s'en attriste en revanche
quand il ya des mauvaises nouvelles il
s'en réjouit soit celle contre est ce
que je peux vous dire sur les emplois
les 1500 emplois c'est que le permis de
construire a été déposé il est il a été
accepté
ces emplois vont venir